this is a P-51 Mustang it's a
streamlined athletic looking plane and
this is the p47 you could have literally
fit a P-51 inside the p47 with room to
spare it simply doesn't look the per but
what if I told you its frame was
purpose-built to fit one incredibly
powerful supercharged engine the massive
pratton Whitney r2800 double wasp a two
Row 18 cylinder aircooled radial engine
with with a massive displacement of 46 L
the Merlin engine of the Spitfire and
P-51 Mustang for comparison one of the
most commonly used Allied engines of
World War II was 27 L and this was just
the power plant the p47 was fitted with
a supercharger that took up a
significant volume of the AFT Fus lash
and this gave the p47 some incredible
high altitude
performance